you played with Dwight and I feel like
like you were saying earlier I feel like
Dwight somehow does not get a fair shake
when we think about the best to play
with oh man because when he was with the
magic like we're talking about like all
NBA leading boat games in the All-Star
game
finals like Dwight beat LeBron in the
finals yeah the Easter finals the white
in the Eastern finals that's what I
meant yeah some of the most disrespect
ever from someone who was a factor on a
Lakers championship team a few years ago
like a couple years ago like yeah yeah
it was incredible what happened with why
does he just rush back from his back
surgery you know I mean he the something
was supposed to take a year I think he
was back moving around in you know four
or five months and he wanted you know to
prove himself was so bad to the Laker
fans and he was never the same you know
the the white I used to play to play for
I never felt more comfortable playing
defense than I knew when Dwight I was
behind me because he was someone that
would lay you out or he can jump to the
top of the backboard and block a shot
yeah Dwight was a beast man and he was
just so [ __ ] strong too so yeah the
white was a monster